I was wondering if you guys could speak
a little to the process of being United
as code directors how exactly does that
happen do you pitch the idea to blue sky
yourselves or do they match you up
that's a that's a great question you
know I think this project actually
brought trying I together and I think it
started because the project had such a
great message and that is the people
having to work together in order to save
the world
in the world of espionage where nobody
trusts each other right
but our experience has been so
collaborative and I think that's been
the biggest thing that we've been trying
to bring throughout the entire
production all the animators back at
blue skies well it's if we're having fun
right that fun will hopefully show up on
the screen so it's it's it's huge
collaboration and that extends to our
vocal challenge as well I completely
disagree we didn't know we didn't know
each other before this movie but now I
couldn't live without them how was it
for you in the booth how is it working
with co-directors are they both in there
with you at the same time or is it one
person handling one day and then another
on another flower yeah no it's just been
so amazing I mean they're so wonderfully
great amazingly brilliant talented
directors and they're so generous with
their time and they would be in the
booth you know like right now you know a
lot of times Troy would be inside and
then I don't know in the booth and it
they would come in and we would be
jamming he would read the other lot
other actors try to get that performance
out of me and this great goodness was so
collaborative and trying to improvise a
lot of things it was just so much fun it
was like being in summer camp and I
could have literally just stayed up
stayed over I know in my sleeping bag
it's your first role voice role in a
full feature if you first yes it's a
voice role in a full feature yes if if
you phrase it that way yes the
experience changed from voicing a
character in a feature film compared to
some of the other formats you worked in
um I think it's just been a
collaborative experience there's a lot
more time to play with so like even
though on one line you could do like 20
50 takes and then you never know what's
going to land but you know we have that
luxury to kind of like build that
character a little bit more so it's been
a lot of fun you know going back the
second time or third time I see oh
that's what the character became and
some
lines changing in the scene the
character grow so that's been a really
collaborative and fun experience now I'm
a New Yorker so I'm not the biggest fan
of pigeon what is this movie gonna do to
kind of turn that around for me you're
gonna love pigeons huh that's I think
the brilliant of Walter's idea right is
that nobody sees pigeons does anything
great but at the end of this film
hopefully you do right because pigeons
are in every major city around the world
and nobody pays any attention to them
much like Walter but at the same time
they have amazing abilities they can fly
ninety two point seven miles per hour
which is real with their eyes on the
side of their head they can see at 360
degree vision so nobody can ever sneak
up behind them and they can see UV light
which is like perimeter lasers and they
can even see electromagnetic pulses
through a wall the opportunity to make a
sequel it should be geese instead of
pigeons because that's also a very
undervalued bird that's true but they
get nothing he's did he except for at
Christmastime happy good to have a goose
story at Christmastime yeah now if we do
one thing with this movie it's to
elevate the pigeon to the truly majestic
bird that it is the pigeon community
thanks you yes it should replace the old
part of a New Yorker you've done it
right fan Sears worldwide that is an
actual term for someone who we've
learned a lot about pigeons over the
course of yes if you guys had to name an
unsung hero of this production who would
it be because we know you guys but
animated movies have so many people on
that credit list at the end and we don't
really know what many of them do which
is not cool that is that's true there's
there's over 550 people back in
Greenwich at blue sky who put their love
and their blood their sweat and their
tears into these movies and and the
truth of it is yet most of them do go
unsung and that is that is crazy so I
would recommend that everyone stays for
the full credit run at the end of the
movie and you will get a feel for how
many people put their effort into it
it's hard to pinpoint just one I think
now I think the entire flock oh well I'm
God the pigeon positive yeah yeah we're
sorry we can't even help it anymore